you
hello everyone we'll be starting in just
a few minutes we'll let give a little
more time for people to join in the
meantime I thought I'd let you all out
of that waiting room and maybe just see
where everyone's calling in from so if
you can text find the chat box and text
in and tell me your location
Portugal Nigeria India I am in Chicago
so again if you can find the chat box
Washington state Ireland
love it where else where is everyone
calling from Houston Texas got a nice
spread of countries states cities so far
I don't think I've seen any two people
in the same place we've got a nice nice
spread again I'm gonna give it just a
couple more minutes it's almost time to
start let's see if we have a few more
people joining before we get started
another Houston oh I think that's two
four Houston Houston is winning I think
I sell two from Houston maybe not maybe
there was just one all right
where else are you calling from that a
nice group on here today thank you all
so much for joining Arlen oh I think
Ireland is winning two people from
Ireland thank you for joining us and
your evening Fort Lauderdale New Orleans
a lot of places I would like to travel
to sometime soon all right well we will
get started just a second
Thank You Martha yes thank you again all
for joining
okay we'll go ahead and get started if
if I haven't met you yet my name is
Angela McDonald and I am a career coach
here with Udacity and today we're gonna
be talking about those gaps in our
resume and when we have that gap and we
dread maybe talking about it thinking
about how to address it and today we're
gonna give you some tips technique
techniques share ideas and give you a
little more confidence to be out there
on the job search so one thing I want to
say too will be I'll talk for about 45
minutes and then we'll have plenty of
time for questions about fifteen minutes
of questions at the end but at any point
in time if you have a question please
type it in the chat box and I will
address questions as I go at the end we
can also unmute and ask questions as
well or if you can't type in the chat
and you want to unmute yourself for a
second that is absolutely fine feel free
to interrupt me at any time and I will
keep everyone muted just so we can avoid
the background noise but in the meantime
you know feel free to use the chat box I
also have ruie on here from Udacity who
can be helping me as well with
addressing any issues or questions that
come up so again we'll have about 45
minutes of content me talking I'd love
for all of you you know I'm gonna be
asking questions getting your input so
please join in type in the chat box you
know if you want it if you want to chat
and and just unmute yourself that's okay
too so let's get started
so again I'm a career coach with Udacity
I'm also a corporate trainer working in
leadership development communication
skills presentation skills based in
Chicago but I've also lived and worked
in America Australia China and Singapore
I was overseas working and living for
about 16 years and I've been back in the
States for a few years now so as you can
imagine moving around those different
places that was because of my husband's
job so in my case it was definitely I
had some gaps at different times that I
had to overcome and work through so I
have a lot of experience myself and
looking a career gap and how I would
address it how he would make sense of it
all to a future employer and also as a
career coach worked with people every
day who have had a gap and trying to
figure out how to help them overcome it
you know kind of fit in with that gap in
their career you can all try to try to
keep yourselves on mute
I will make sure we're all muted now and
really if you wouldn't mind just hitting
mute all if we hear some background
noise that would be great
alright so what are we gonna talk about
today first of all building career
confidence and what I find in my
experience is when someone's had a gap
the number one challenge for them is
building up that confidence again
building the confidence to talk to
someone about about the gap about maybe
where they feel like that's a weakness
in their current career and how they can
talk about it and and feel confident
going back into the workplace especially
especially if it's been a longer gap
we're going to talk about strategies to
discuss your gap and we're gonna look at
resume strategies a little bit for
addressing the gap and well as well and
again the do's and the don'ts of the gap
discussion
so gaps happen we all know that right we
know that they're going to happen they
can be that you stayed home to care for
children or family members you took a
sabbatical you lost your job Medical
Leave you took time off to study
whatever the reason it's okay to have a
gap a lot of people have it you're not
the only one I know it feel it can feel
like that sometimes or you're surrounded
maybe by a lot of people not working and
you really know you want to go back to
work and it's hard to get yourself back
in that professional mindset and feel
the confidence to go back so they happen
and we just have to find ways to tell
our story and folk and really be future
focused
so I'd like to put a pull up here to ask
you why you had a gap and remember gaps
are okay and it's really to help me as
we're talking today to to position a
little bit of our discussion more
specifically if I know where some of you
are coming from what your reason is for
your personal gap so if you should see
the pull up on the screen now why do you
have a gap in your career history and I
meant to put an other category there and
forgot so if one of those does doesn't
fit you I'm sorry about that I know
there are just other reasons as well I
try to think of the most common ones
that I know of
again don't feel self-conscious about
your gap hey we're all on here because
we've had a gap we're in a gap or maybe
there's a gap in our future so feel free
to one of the first things to be able to
talk about is what is that guy your
names are not going to come up in this
pulling so I'd love to get some feel it
looks like we've got a lot of people who
have the gap because they wanted to
concentrate on their studies we have
several of you who have stayed home with
your children and then we've got a
spread of other people with maybe a
family illness lost your job several of
you again remember we all know that
happens so give that let the pool stamp
for just another minute
not quite a minute give you a few more
seconds in case you're not at your
computer and maybe you're trying to look
at someone typed in they took a inter
intentional one-year sabbatical I hope
you did something fabulous Leah
I know a lot of times people take a
sabbatical and they go through times and
that sabbatical where they feel like
it's the best thing and most amazing
thing they've ever done and it feels so
good and other times a little guilt sets
in or a little bit of fear sets in so I
hope you were able to enjoy your
one-year or maybe you're still in your
one year and you're enjoying it so and
the pulling now like we've got a lot of
you there I'll share the results so you
can all see that you are not alone so
you can see here staying home with
children caring for family sabbaticals
concentrate on studies Anita said that
she couldn't see the gap and but because
of work visa issues and then family
responsibilities so ok Florian yes I do
know what it's like so again thank you
all for joining in the pool someone said
that there was downsizing and then
studying upgrading yeah sometimes a gap
happens not by our own decision but then
we turn it into an opportunity and it
sounds like you know Fredrika Syd
mentioned he was downsized but then now
he's taking that time to study and
upgrade some skills so that's excellent
all right
so again remember whatever the reason
whatever that reason for your gap you're
not the only one you're absolutely not
the I touch people all the time they
think oh you know I don't have those
skills everybody else does I haven't
done this and there's so many people
taking time off to have a gap and it's a
great time in our history and in the
world that we have the opportunity to go
back to work I was talking to someone
recently who was a bit older and said
they they had to quit their job as soon
as they found out they were pregnant
they would just weren't allowed to keep
working and they weren't allowed to come
back so we don't live in those times
anymore unfortunately so that's all
that's the good news right so I'd like
to get some thoughts out there about
what concerns you the most about your
gap what do what is the specific fear or
concern that you have is it that your
technical skills aren't up to date which
I know many of you are working on in one
way or another because that's why we're
here at Udacity
or is it the perception that someone
might have of you is it that you don't
know how to talk about what you've been
doing so just give me a few ideas there
then and I know all of everything I said
of all of the above
have all been something I've thought
about so just give me a few of your
thoughts here I'm like what concerns you
the most about your gap in talking about
it so once this technical skills in
ageism absolutely those are definite
things that come up that we think about
the method of framing is just putting it
together right and talking about it
interviewers always highlight it that's
right now hi that's that's the annoying
part isn't it
someone said they didn't get ten years
maybe maybe you spent a lot of time in
the peak maybe a PhD University setting
but you didn't get tenure so now you're
taking the time to go do something else
and then you have to talk about it and
and just kind of tying in - and I'll
talk it about this at the very end but
it's definitely next week we're gonna
talk about how to deal with your
greatest weakness question and for a lot
of you that greatest weakness might be
the exact topic we're talking about
today so you get a little ahead of the
game there Matthew says it's the
perception of maybe someone thinking
you're lazy good good comment there's
there are definitely some people who
don't appreciate the gap that that it
might think that and quite honestly
maybe that's the first sign that you
don't want to work for that person and
he says my concern is that I still have
family responsibilities of the kids so
my priority is for a part-time job but
if I put that constraint I'm worried
I'll not I won't be able to start again
okay well and we'll talk a lot about
that in the today and the opportunities
that are out there and some resources
that you can find where certain
companies and organizations can really
aren't starting to embrace more
part-time workers and flex time as well
Florence's facing resistance from HR
rejected before being considered
basically afraid of being stopped at the
gatekeeper good point very good point
those are real all of these are real
things that I think that I hope as
you're all reading the comments as well
and thinking yes that's me too because I
think that's the great thing about
having us all on here today is we've all
been there
what if you technical skills how to
frame the gap I'm seeing what if you
were unable to clear a few subjects and
had to repeat a year okay so maybe in
your studies you had a little extra time
there that fear of just getting left
behind that's that's it that's a good
one too and maybe if you think about
having the gap or planning the gap and
getting left behind
so thank you all for those thoughts
again I hope you're reading them and
realizing again that all of us have very
similar thoughts and feelings about it
and again I think that's in the
workplace today people are a lot more
open but in given that they're open we
stuff to be very confident in our
message in our story and our approach to
talking about the gap and that's why I
think and I noticed even myself as the
course of moving around and different
times and having gaps either with my
kids or just because we had moved and I
noticed many years ago through that
maybe that probably not soon enough is
that when people would ask me what I had
been doing I would maybe talk kind of
around eight different things and it I
didn't have a really clear message so I
realized when I started looking for a
job and started approaching people about
working whether it was just to start
networking or actually interviewing I
had to have that story tied up I had to
have my pitch my positioning of who I am
and where I want to go so that I felt
confident in myself and the people
interviewing me felt confident the could
that felt and heard that confidence in
me so that's why we want to prepare yes
people are more open yes people are
going back to work after gaps but we
can't just show up and pretend it didn't
happen and know how to talk about it
so number one thing is building that
confidence we want to build that career
confidence and there's really three
areas that we can think about that can
really help us with us and one is we
want to make sure we're relevant we want
to update our knowledge in the field
that we're entering again if you've
taken a gap and you're going back you
want to make sure you've really become
real you're staying relevant you might
not have stayed relevant and if you stay
at home with your kids for seven years
but there's ways to get back to being
relevant you want to start networking
and feeling professionally connected
with people where you want to work or
even people who inspire you maybe to go
back to work you want to show again that
confidence know your pitch and address
that gap so you can start being future
focused and not dwelling on that gap so
let's look at each one of these one at a
time
you
so first is to be relevant what can we
do to be relevant so let's imagine
you've taken that year that three years
that five years at the eight years
whatever it is and you're starting to
think about going back to work and many
of you have obviously already had
decided to take a Udacity class to help
you be relevant which is awesome other
things to do is start following industry
blogs make sure you're up-to-date on I
think you know maybe myself I was in
banking for many years and early in my
career if I was going to go back into
banking I would start following on
LinkedIn or and or in the Wall Street
Journal and making sure I'm reading the
news and following people's blogs and
following websites so I know what's the
terminology out there what are people
talking about what are the hot topics
follow top companies on LinkedIn follow
the influencers on LinkedIn educate
yourself on new office technology if you
know one thing that I think that I hear
a lot is people will say well I don't
know how to do that or I'm not sure
about that you know and some of the
things are so simple that you can easily
research it and talk to people before
you go back and start working in that
environment so I don't know maybe if we
imagine someone who took a maybe their
their gap was at the time we went from
fax machines to email and they got back
they were going back to work and said
well I don't know how to use email
figure it out before you go interview
figure out if there's a if they're using
slack or if they're using a technology
and I'm I think all of you this
particular audience I think where you
have a definitely a leg up on people in
other industries is that you are
obviously technically savvy and you're
upgrading your skills already with
Udacity so I think that being relevant
from a technical standpoint you should
be in typically pretty good shape I know
that there are certain technical skills
you wish we're stronger you wish you had
more experience in but that will come
you're not completely non-relevant but
again staying up to date if you're
programming
and a language that maybe is not as
prevalent today as it was when you were
working that's a little I know a lot of
you are doing is upgrading those
programming skills so one is kind of the
technical side of being relevant but
also just the industry what people are
talking about and when you think about
those influencers there's you know
playing around with LinkedIn and
figuring out how to get be reading the
right posts and following the right
people one of the things to do is find
someone who does the job you want so
let's say I want to be a digital
marketer and I've been taking classes
and I know I want to be a digital
marketing manager I'm gonna go and look
at other people's profiles and see what
groups are they in who do they follow
what companies do they follow who have
they worked for and then I'm gonna start
kind of trolling around and looking at
those companies and those those groups
and see which ones I might want to join
in my case when I moved from Singapore
back to America I knew that I wanted to
stay in corporate training and career
coaching so I started finding people who
were trainers and coaches in America in
Chicago area looking at the companies
they work for who they've contracted
with which groups are in who they follow
and I started joining groups and
listening to conversations and you know
in the beginning you might be a bit of
just the voyeur right you're just kind
of reading and looking and seeing what
people are doing and then gradually you
might start liking some other posts or
then you might start commenting on some
of their posts and you'll find the as
you start educating yourself in the
industry news and the company news you
start feeling much more relevant pretty
quickly and as you go out to interview
you will and network you'll feel like
you can be a part of the conversation
and that's you know it's something
that's not that hard to do but I can't
believe how many people will tell me
they've you know gone back to take these
finance classes and they want to go work
for a bank and I'll say okay who do you
think are your top five banks you'd like
to work for and they haven't really even
looked into any of them so get to know
your field get to know the companies if
see the drone on there if you're working
want to work in AI for a company that is
making the technology in technology and
drones then know those top drone
companies find out who the big players
are who's blogging about it who's
talking about it get in the conversation
and remember you can be that you can be
the fly on the wall for a while that's
the great thing about like the social
media you can join one of these groups
that has 3,000 people in it and just be
the fly on the wall that's that's
listening and reading and not really you
don't have to participate immediately
until you feel you've built up that
confidence
any questions on this slide and being
relevant and some of the things I
mentioned just pause here for a second
and if you have any specific questions I
can address those now
give you a few seconds to type your
message if that's what anyone is doing
or if you need to unmute yourself and
just ask a quick question that's okay
too
all right so obviously kind of goes
without saying as you see on here
several of these items connect into
LinkedIn so obviously having a really
strong LinkedIn profile is important as
well and we have done some webinars on
those and we have a career project with
LinkedIn and as coaches we also help you
with your LinkedIn profile okay the next
one was network and again we've done
other webinars on it networking it when
we could spend an hour just talking
about networking but I wanted to just
touch on it quickly here to think about
remember that first step we want to be
relevant we want to make sure update if
you wanted to start networking and you
haven't done a little of your research
and feeling like you're starting to gain
a little bit of that relevancy through
reading and talking maybe to closer
friends closer classmates that you might
have had then once you feel like you've
you've you feel a little more relevant
you've had some conversations with the
people tighter in your circle then it's
time to branch out and network because
you again you as you think about going
into this next position you want to
start talking to people and it may not
be and it shouldn't be in the very
beginning hey I need a job but but but
reconnecting saying you know what I was
got my PhD in medicine but I've decided
to kind of take a data analytics
approach to things and took some time
off to take these classes I'd love to
hear what you're doing now having
conversations finding out what other
people are doing letting them know what
you're doing
so that you start again you're you're
gaining all that knowledge it helps you
become more relevant you start exploring
the options that are out there
again part of that is the online groups
and discussions as you be get your the
fly on the wall for a while then you
want to start engaging and you might
look for meetup events Eventbrite or
alumni events
one of the questions that came up is a
lot of companies want two to five years
experience even though they say graduate
rules how do you fill this gap as a
graduate I think that sometimes that
especially when I hear that two to five
years of experience depending on the
position a lot of times they're just
looking for someone with some work
experience so if you have other work
experience and you've proven yourself
and technically you can overcome that I
think once they're asking for someone
with over five years that starts looking
at you know maybe they need management
experience maybe they need much higher
level technical experience in working
with something for enough time so I
think under five years yeah it's kind of
annoying when they say it's a graduate
role but yet they want three years of
experience so it's a little funny that
way not quite not quite right is it
so I say and and while we're on that one
thing to try not to get too caught up on
this every detail in the job description
a lot of skills transfer over from your
different experiences and remember job
descriptions were put together as I go
this would be the best case scenario but
they're not gonna get every box ticked
on there and when you're looking at job
descriptions don't get caught up in
every bullet point every detail you read
the job description and you think you
know what I can do this that's number
one number two is do I meet most of the
requirements and qualifications that
they're looking for most you know I say
I say around 75% and if those two things
are good then that's kind of like you
it's met the cut apply does it let them
take the time to decide if they went to
interview you or not don't I know you
should be applying for obviously a lot
of jobs so if you spent the time with
every little detail can really slow you
down
next is this preparation and really
being prepared to address the gap and
again we we want to prepare it just as
much as we prepare an elevator pitch is
similar we want to prepare a lot of our
answers for interviews and think about
what we want to say and addressing the
gap is one of the biggest and again we
want to show that we believe in
ourselves so that others can believe in
us to want to show the confidence in
ourselves so they have confidence as
well and you really need a strategy
to discuss the gap and that's what we're
going to talk about next
Ramaiah says most of the returned ship
opportunities and companies have a
minimum experience required as five
years yeah I have noticed that return
ships are definitely right now targeting
people with who may have had like a
quite a bit of a career and then I think
from what I see most of it it's like I
had a career I stayed home with my kids
for quite a long time and now I'm going
back it tends to be where those returned
ships are focused and I'll give you some
resources at the very end where you can
look for some other opportunities
besides just a returned ship
so this is the strategy that I think is
very effective for answering the
question why do you have a gap in your
career or however they ask it they might
say well what did you do for the last
five years or what what can you tell me
a little bit about your background I
noticed you had you've taken some time
off however they ask it this strategy
can help you just get a very concise
answer and proceed into that interview
with confidence and get past that first
screening question so first thing you
want to do is the three steps state it
fill it close it it sounds simple when
you just make it three little steps
right we're gonna go into each one in
more detail so state the gap why were
you unemployed simple enough very quick
very simple don't tell them the big life
story of whatever you did if it was your
sabbatical you don't need to say you
know talk about the the year in Bali or
wherever it was or if it was you know
you just say it quickly don't go into
the uses of what you did daily or that
you were you know volunteering at your
kids school and talk about all the
different events you did just really
quickly why were you unemployed then the
fill the gap is what did you do during
the gap and this is where we'll go into
a little more detail you just highlight
some of the things that are most
relevant to maybe the job that you're
looking at but most importantly and
where you want to spend most of your
time as that third step closing the gap
what do you want to do next
basically closing the gap is saying
forget about this this is what I'm gonna
do now this is where my future is this
is where I want to go and grow so let's
look at each of those in detail
state it how should you state it you
should be honest direct and concise
again you don't need to go into well I
kind of decided to do this and I wasn't
sure and then I decided and maybe this
and just very quickly I decided that I
wasn't growing in my previous role I
took a couple years off to study and
expand my skills boom that's all you
have to say okay
what did you do during the gap and think
about even if some of the things you did
were in the last two months of the gap
right maybe you spent five years home
with your kids and you were just
entrenched in diapers and preschool
that's okay but maybe in the last six
months you started ramping up and doing
something you've done some freelancing
you've worked on projects you've
attended events or you've planned events
different meetings and workshops maybe
you did some writing maybe where you
were blogging what continuing education
did you do did you take some classes
along the way or maybe you just ramped
up right at the end maybe you had some
community involvement some volunteer
work some mentoring and again like fill
it with the most important pick and
choose what you might tell them because
you don't want to stay on this too long
you want to highlight a few things that
are relevant to the professional work
you might be doing and and if you don't
feel like you have anything super
superest specifically relevant then just
highlight real quick I was involved a
lot with my children's school and a
charity in the city that feeds hungry
children whatever it is and then and
then move on if you did a lot of
different things if you like you can
talk a little bit about freelancing and
projects then maybe you'll spend a
little more time on this but again we
don't want to go too long because we
really want to focus on step three what
do you want to do now and this is where
you need to show your excitement about
relaunching your career you want to show
your commitment and you want to be clear
about the job you want so if we think
about those a lot of times I know that
when people are deciding to go back to
work there is that time where they're
going I think I want to do it oh but I'm
kind of feeling still maybe pulled by
family in this direction but I know this
is what I want there you go back and
forth and back and forth and that's
completely normal but when you're in the
interview all that waffling has to go
away and you have to say I am so excited
to go back to work I'm ready to go back
and dive in full-time and
I'm really wanting to be you know a
Python programmer and I've been spending
the last six months of creating these
skills
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah this is where
you want to be very future focused and
spend your time and show that excitement
and commitment so I'm gonna just pop
back to that slide that showed the three
steps and ask if you have any questions
about state it fill it close it
I know it's a lot to take in it's a lot
to think about how you're going to
position it it's a good thing to talk
about with a career coach if you have
the opportunity get some ideas down
write it down practice it don't
necessarily memorize it but but feel
like you've packaged up your message I
often tell people sometimes we have to
imagine in an interview when someone
asks this question or tell us about
yourself once you'd imagine you're
handing them a present you need to tie
up your story with a pretty bow and hand
it to them on a silver platter because
if you wobble if you're unsure if you're
if you go around in circles if you're
not very clear your confidence will go
down and you you've lost the opportunity
so state it fill it close it any
questions on those three steps again at
this time if you want to unmute yourself
and ask a question that's absolutely
fine or if you would like to type
something I've got to add a nice long
one here and let me take a look I was
unemployed because of the work visa
issue at first and then because of
family but invested my time in acquiring
new skills and learned programming and
data analysis tools like blah blah blah
I enjoyed working in different
supervised learning projects and
different domains now I'm so excited to
be a data analyst and work on real-life
business scenarios Aneta that's awesome
you just stated it filling it and closed
it perfectly I love how you that first
sentence very concise very to the point
it's really no one's I mean they really
don't have to know why you ever took
time off but it's it is easier and
better and it shows a lot more
transparency and honestly honesty when
you do just say it and even even if it's
personal issues but I think sometimes if
you can say the reason if and most
people can there are some like much more
personal issues that maybe you don't
want to and you just say personal issues
I think sometimes that could make
someone wonder and their their
imagination could
wonder things you don't want them to
wonder so the more honest you can be and
direct and quick I think is better and
yes any that you addressed all three
points very good and that you know one
of the key things that like someone said
earlier is that sometimes you know in
the interview process someone it's like
they they get stuck on that gap and
that's where if you have this nice tight
again I need a package did all at for
him and hand it to him with a bow around
it now all they should be talking about
is the future and her in this position
they shouldn't keep addressing the gap
she's addressed it move on okay if you
think of other questions or you want to
write yourself feel free and I will
comment
otherwise I will go ahead and move on
just check our timing still doing good I
know one of the things that comes up is
happen and I've done a lot of research
on this topic and people talk about like
what benefits you gained by having a gap
and think about and this is like kind of
when you think about that step where you
fill it and think about the benefits you
gained by having a gap what did you
learn what did you experience like in my
case I I guess I think about a couple of
my gaps when I moved to other countries
I have the opportunity to focus on
learning some of the language exploring
a new culture and kind of settling in
and having that time to to really have
that travel experience and and in
language learning experience and I could
talk a little bit about that benefit in
a very quick way sometimes they'll ask
you what how do you think you benefited
from this gap so any thoughts there does
anyone want to comment on what they
think they benefited the most when you
think right now if you're at the I'm
assuming everyone here is had a gap or
and again I guess I should have asked
that at the beginning as well well
for now it looks like from the
conversation most of you have what when
you think back to a certain gap you had
what are you so grateful that you
learned from it now it might be that you
learned you know if you took it might
not be something that you learn taking a
class but it might be something that you
learned five voluntee
you
anyone want to comment on something that
they might think about
oh it looks like I am muted one seconds
you
okay I think I'm unmuted now sorry if
you missed something it looks like I was
needed for a second
so anyone think of anything that they
feel like they might have they're so
grateful for that they took the time to
learn or understand while they were off
I know for me part of it when I moved to
China was learning Mandarin please don't
ask me to speak it right now I should
have learned more than I did but I did
get some exposure and feel happy about
it
I know that some people have taken time
off maybe to care for family in another
country and being able to have that time
with family and alert and they balance a
lot of things but it also made them
realize how much they do love having
their own professional life someone said
learning and being able to recover from
the gap absolutely when you've lost your
job when you've been made redundant and
some things happen with your company
that as much you most you don't want to
experience a lot of what you experience
and it really does teach you to be maybe
a little more creative and find new ways
to do something Florian said for me it's
simply the way forward is much clearer I
had to tackle some personal issues as
well so my mind is much more free to get
to this next step but that's great I
think I see that as well I think that
sometimes when we take a break from work
and especially if we've worked in one
field for a long time we can kind of see
like you know what I realized is I
really like this part of what I did but
I not this or I really liked working for
this type of company but not that type
so a lot of those things start to
clarify we invest time to learn skills
very good I will back up to a one
question someone said how do we look for
influencers on LinkedIn the way I like
to do it is again I found when I moved
back to Chicago just to use my example
since I kind of know it firsthand I
found people who were corporate trainers
I just googled corporate trainers for
your coaches whatever it was found who
they worked for then went to clicked on
those companies looked at then some of
the people that worked for them and then
looked at who those people were
following and then maybe try to find the
president or the CEO and see who they
might follow or actually follow them and
see and just kind of you know do some
digging a little detective work that way
and if you know anyone that's pretty
active on LinkedIn or social media that
you can say you know in digital
marketing who do you like to follow what
news do you like to keep up with
I know I found some great blogs for data
analysts that I'm not a data analyst but
that I found for other people that I
think are really great and they'll often
quote our or you know quote people who
have written something or publish in
their blog something that someone else
is written and so you can find the names
that way
so I think it's so first step obviously
we want to we want to go through that
three-step process and prepare this
discussion about the gap but there's
always gonna be that person that wants
to know more what did you do what
benefits did you gain and you might have
to expand a little more because they've
asked you about it so what are the some
of the ideas that we have about the
benefits that we gained and we've you
all have already mentioned a few of
these you had time to reflect on the
past and future goals you had a little
more clarity a little more sure of what
you want you were able to have the time
to dedicate to learning new skills and
sometimes that renewed energy in your
career and you know and think about like
everyone's got some you know a lot of
people do volunteer work when they take
time off and finding that that they were
able to give some of their time which is
very rewarding and something you don't
have enough time to do when you're
working full time Martha said a lot of
clarity and knowing the direction I want
to go in
what's the field to take I'm happy to go
into and advance in also the location
choices I choose to live in are now more
clear I upskilled and have a better
opportunity to work in an area and
location that I like that's great those
are all great ways to - again it shows
your confidence and it shows that
sureness and yourself and what you want
a few I would talk about resume for a
little bit in general obviously there
will be a gap somewhere and a few of the
ways you can help and I think more so
again we're not hiding the gap we're not
trying to say something happened that
didn't but we want to highlight we want
to be more future focused and we want to
highlight the most relevant information
so first we want to lead again this is
where you all are very fortunate having
the technical skills that you do and
taking the Udacity courses and knowing
you're already upgrading here so leading
your resume with technical skills and
core competencies and you might have
heard of the term functional resume or
chronological resume chronological
resume is very traditional where you
would kind of go in order of time and
then it always starts with the education
and then the work experience and and
that's really that traditional way isn't
super common especially in tech because
if we think what do they want to know
first what's the most important
information it's going to be those
technical skills and core competencies
so I really encourage people to in the
order of their resume and this is really
people in tech in general and especially
people with a gap because it draws
attention to what's most important not
the gap so if we look at excuse me
if we look at got your contact details
up top then having a strong professional
objective that states a little bit about
who you are what you're looking for
leading in with those technical skills
and core competencies and highlight some
newly developed skills maybe you maybe
you go straight into projects at that
point to show the relevant work you've
been doing maybe you did a little
freelance work also I think one thing
that is a lot of people in tech I've
noticed overlooked is and then some of
the freelance or project work that they
did while they were out of work that is
actually pretty valuable so if you you
know if you were asked by a neighbor to
do something for their business if you
were asked by the school board to do
something to their website or run do
some data analytics for them think about
those as like putting on your resume
that maybe you were you know freelance
in a certain field or had your own kind
of volunteer independent contractor so
if you've done enough projects to
justify that then definitely include
that on your resume that you don't have
to have a formal business license to say
you were an independent contractor on
your resume but you want to have real
projects that you've done so you can
talk about them you don't want to just
to make sure I'm totally clear that you
don't want to call yourself an
independent contractor if you didn't
actually do anything you want to make
sure hey I was an independent contractor
for the last three years how many
projects did I do
write them down make sure you can talk
about them so this is some general
on resume remember you're not hiding the
gap you're just raising to the top the
most important information that they
need to see
any questions on resume
all right we're gonna talk about a few
do's and don'ts and then we will open it
up for Q&A so we talked about some of
these but just to make sure we've got
them all on here these are things you do
want to do you want to obviously address
the gap you don't want to try to hide it
you don't want to try to pretend it
didn't happen
you want to be very clear with your
goals remember it's okay to feel unsure
it's okay to feel nervous it's okay to
feel like you've got one foot in with
your family and one foot it work work
mind and you're not sure somedays but
when you go in there to interview you
want to make sure it's absolutely yes I
want to work and you know if things
change that's okay but right then you
need to be confident and sure of
yourself and articulate your message
with confidence you want to be future
focus and really have that growth
mindset I'm going to show you a slide
here in a minute about really focusing
on that growth mindset and be sure you
want to work be sure that you've really
thought through the process if you've
taken a long time especially and you're
not you know again be sure you want it
but don't feel bad when you have those
thoughts that you think oh I I should
really be still taking care of my
parents or I should be home with my kids
or what if I should be doing this you
can find a way to balance it and you're
not going to know if you can do it until
you get out there and start trying
and then find a support network find
people you can talk to maybe other
people who are looking for jobs friends
colleagues ex colleagues that you talk
to that you can get that support network
and ask for help ask people for
conversations ask people to look at your
resume you know reach out to some of
those professional contacts that you
have and/or good friends that also might
be working another area business and and
don't be afraid to ask for help
you
so here we want to just take a quick
look at that growth mindset and if you
read some of that information in there
failure is an opportunity to grow I know
you know that's kind of a you know and I
think about a gap a gap is an
opportunity grit wasn't a failure but it
was a gap it but the belief that you can
learn to do anything you want that
challenges help you grow that your
effort and attitude determine your
abilities not what someone else thinks
they should be that feedback is
constructive that you're inspired by the
success of others and you'd like to try
new things and another thing with that
growth mindset is you know I hear a lot
of people say oh I'll never be able to
go back to work I've been out too long
or oh no one's gonna want to hire me
because I took this break the that
thinking has to go way way way way out
the window and breathe if you're feeling
stuck read this growth mindset keep that
growth mindset there's a great book on
the growth mindset that I cannot think
of the title and author at this moment
but maybe before we finish
but Google growth mindset and books and
you'll find it this fixed mindset is is
that I'm either good at or am i I had a
gap I can do it or I can't I don't I
can't control my destiny we don't want
to have this fixed mindset we want to
make sure we're really focused on that
growth mindset I'm gonna answer Martha's
question here resume and in general
question if you have a gap in lacking a
visa to work in example New York City
how would you approach getting work in
New York City you're coming from Ireland
as you travel to limes I might go to
offer some advice and place of support
and filling the gap in the visa
challenge yes the visa is a big
challenge I would say in text
specifically it's a little easier but it
will take I think the most important
thing to get there is to start reaching
out to people start making connections
in the area you want to go so let's say
it's New York City and you could
start finding people in a similar field
ask them to have a conversation maybe
you find someone who went to your same
university and they're in New York and
you could ask them hey do you have time
to chat start building some
relationships people you know there are
some executive recruiters if you're at a
high enough level that you can reach out
to it they will help with the visa
process typically that's at much higher
level positions in the lower middle
positions that's not as likely again I
think building the relationships trying
to talk to recruiters people in HR
people in the field and see if you can
get some momentum there that's one of
the best ways to start with that what do
we don't want to do we don't want to
dodge the question of the gap right here
we hit we need to address it we talked
about the three-step process we're gonna
be ready for that we don't want to dwell
on the gap we don't want to be like oh
you know what I took five years off and
now I don't know if I can do that and
but I'm really gonna try and you know
maybe I shouldn't have done it
like forget all that language that's not
confident and you're dwelling on it and
you can kind of go into a spiral and
don't let the gap hold you back don't
don't let the fear of talking about it
or the fear of getting back to work be
the thing that holds you back and also
you know I didn't put this on there but
something I think about too is a lot of
people I help with I say you know that
first foot back in the door is really
all you need that first opportunity it
might take a while to find it but once
you get that first work experience in it
may not it probably won't be your dream
job it probably won't be where you even
think you should be based on what you've
already done in your career but get in
there prove yourself work hard they'll
see it you'll make sure you're doing all
the right things to hopefully move up as
soon as you can and if they don't see it
well then you've got great experience on
your resume and it's time to move on so
know that that first step in may not be
the most ideal or dream position that
you're looking for
and don't discuss it with uncertainty
right don't you can talk to your talk to
your friends over a drink if you want to
talk about like oh my gosh I'm nervous
about going back don't talk about that
to the interviewer okay talk to your
coach talk to your friends talk to your
tight like your your spouse your family
members about that nervousness about
that uncertainty because that's normal
but don't have it in the interview and
don't same thing don't show those
insecurities about going back and having
that gap these are some resources that I
found and I will say these are mostly
us-based that I'm aware of
however they are pretty big
organizations a lot of them so they
might be something that can help you a
lot of them are female focused so that's
something to keep in mind sorry guys
there's not as much of a maybe networker
camaraderie of this type of thing for
men but I think that some of these could
also help you as well if anything even
there the blogs and the posts that they
put out there kind of walk through each
one and I don't know a ton about all of
them but I know enough people that have
I've read through their websites and a
little familiar with them the mom
project in the apprai group are very
similar there they they are basically
recruiters and they partner with
companies and have job listings that you
can apply for in their positions that
are open to someone who has had a gap
essentially and the mom project is free
from what I can still see the approp is
a fee involved I relaunch and career
contessa are both have job listings and
they also have a lot of great articles
lean in you might know from Sheryl
Sandberg she wrote a book she has a
great site they lean in groups around if
you're looking for other people too
build a professional network this would
be a great place to look I believe a
prey group also has or um that's right
at the bottom one elevate network also
has groups
I think elevate you do there's more of a
fee involved from the last time I saw
path forward org is I don't know that
one as well but I did find it and
thought it would look too resourceful so
take a screenshot how about that and
explore all of those and see what you
can find the slide deck will be
available actually this will all go out
on YouTube and you'll get an email
letting us know letting you know when it
comes
so those are the resources that I found
to date that I like if you know of any
more please feel free to type it in now
I would love to know them I'm sure
everyone else would I think that the
again someone mentioned earlier their
return ships and I think there is a
website that one of I think it might be
I real onch
shows those reach a lot of different
return ships that are out there and if
you're not familiar with the term return
ship it's basically an internship for
older people who have worked taking time
off and they want to go back to work and
it is a set time it might be a six-month
type of job and it's usually rotations
in most cases that I've seen where you
can go back rotate around in an area
that interests you and then after the
six months and rotating did three or
four divisions figure out the spot
that's best for you
looks like a couple people want the data
analyst resources I mentioned I will if
you could message me on slack or in the
student hub then I can send that to you
that's gonna be the best way for me to
get you if you want any additional
information that I might have mentioned
that wasn't in the slide deck please
email me directly are not sorry not
email slack or student hub message me
and I'll get it to you Martha said women
in tech LGBTQ have some specific groups
for networking you can just google tech
in whatever area you're in I know some
people network by a teaching
volunteering and youth coding and
mentoring groups that's a great idea I
think that the anytime and you're in a
certain area if you're a woman and you
look for women in tech or if you've got
a specific volunteer match org has where
you can find places to volunteer in your
area that are in your area of interest
so yeah googling and searching for some
volunteer work and some groups like that
are great someone asked me what my slack
ideas that's a good question I don't
know really if you can see it and type
it in I think it's Angela career coach
or career coach Angela something like
that sorry I forget if you go if you're
in the careers channel if you are on
slacking or in the careers channel you
should be able to find me pretty easily
but maybe if ruie from Udacity is on and
could type that out that would be great
an enthusiasts group like drone flying
may be a way to build friendships for
men as well and hackathons online those
are all great those are kind of those
great ways to think about networking and
there should be when you get the we have
we keep most of our webinars on YouTube
and there is one all about networking
and a lot of these similar ideas are out
there on how to get out and get involved
so that's great thank you so much for
those Martha
okay IBM coders have competitions
wonderful all right I know we are
getting to the end of our time I want to
let you know about our next workshop and
then I'm gonna be on for about another
five or ten minutes for questions so our
next one I'm excited about - it's an
interview workshop if you haven't
attended an interview workshop it is the
one of the coaches runs it we only talk
for maybe 10 15 minutes at the most and
then the remaining time is practice
interviewing practice questions with a
group of other Udacity students in
breakout rooms through zoom so it's not
where you it's not as maybe information
heavy sharing as this career webinar
here so the interview workshop is up on
the slide now it is June or sorry July
10th and think you really put the event
details in so you can click on that
again please plan on coming and
participating I know some people come
and then they just sit and listen and it
kind of makes it hard for the other
people who are having the confidence and
taking some risk out there to practice
and they're really helpful peer ask the
link to the slack group oh I'm sorry I
don't if you're on the student hub you
can send me a message there I know some
people are on student hums some people
are on slack it really depends on which
nanodegree you're in
uh-oh Thank You Rui she typed in where'd
he get help with the request
all right so that is the end of my
content and would love to throw it out
there for questions I know some people
are asking about the career Channel if
you can email you see down at the bottom
of my screen career - support at
udacity.com or you can just for slack in
those things you could just type in
support at udacity.com and they can help
you get on the student hub career
channel or the slack channel whichever
you might be a part of I think the
majority of if your nano degree is
started recently most of it is all going
to student hub but there's still a lot
of us on slack as well I'm in both I'm
gonna find me in either place so
questions questions questions about this
content questions about preparing for
your career what questions might you
have and again as you think
yes go ahead hi I wanted to know now how
do we compete with all the fresh
graduates and all the people who have
had so many years of experience in the
industry because now we have had a gap
and we are learning new skills how do we
compete with them because they will
always get preference you know I think
that well the first thing you're
probably doing is is upscaling for
Udacity I think getting a lot of doing
as many projects as you can to make sure
you know if it's if it's Python that was
the the one skill you felt like you
really needed to upskill in so not only
taking the class but doing some open
source projects doing some competitions
doing some even the practice so you can
get through those interviews where you
might have a coding challenge and so
that would really be the first step and
then to really think about all your
other strengths the strengths you have
in the experience that think about the
different work experience you have had
and the what you can pull from those
different experiences because remember
there's always so many transferable
skills that we get in every position
that we want to make sure we think about
those and talk about those to show that
you know hey I might not have been you
know sitting at my desk
every day for the last two years but I
have done all of these projects and I've
managed teams and I've led projects and
I've you know whatever else you might
have done in your career that can be
really great transferable skills okay
I'll try that yeah another question
please yep
does Udacity have those kind of
technical platforms great we have coding
challenges I am not aware of any
specifically that Udacity has but I know
I know there's a lot of resources I know
I've shared those in different forums
especially with Python so if you message
me later I could send you some of those
links and if I have and I'll help you
find the ones specifically that you're
looking for hacker rank I know is one of
the big ones okay that a lot of people
do like oh if I had says the algorithm
thank you so much yeah one of the
comments was just that the data
structure and algorithm nana degree has
those not sure if he's talking about
challenges or if he's talking about red
can you tell us is that are you talking
about a channel or are you talking about
challenges challenges okay yes and I
have heard the data structure in
algorithms nanodegree is a newer one and
I've heard a lot of people who are going
back to work taking that because it will
help a lot in the interview process as
well okay thank you so much yes can you
please advise well let me jump up here
oh I think that just got answered
I think Martha your question got
answered by now there's a lot of
questions about student hub and slack so
ruies typing some information in there
okay she also and the chat you'll see
that where we put some interviewing
resources for coding practice a link
there that is on our site so that's
great Thank You Rory is there a way to
add myself to the email yes I would
email career - support at Udacity comm I
do have another meeting coming up in
just a couple minutes so I do have to
kind of keep us to our time and I know
all of you are busy thank you so much
for all of you for attending I hope that
it helped you feel like you know how to
address the gap go in with a little more
confidence start positioning yourself in
a way that you can go in and say hey I'm
ready to work and these are all the
great things about me and and use these
tools this webinar was recorded even me
talking and in the camera the whole time
which is not as much fun for me but I'm
glad you all chimed in I loved having
the chat on here it was fantastic he
said let the dog out yes I think my dogs
are ready for a little attention as well
hopefully he do that for a minute
between meetings thank you sorry about
the doggies in the background thank you
again everyone have a wonderful week
good luck with your career and I hope to
be talking to you all again soon or
seeing you in the next workshop thank
you bye
you